[موسيقى]
كان guisan العام في الواقع
هو في الواقع زميل ضرائب
من نابليون إلى بري ليس أنه الصيف
مدرسة بريان في نفس الوقت
الآن هذا نابليون
إذا مات ثم واحد من الأخير
الناس الذين رأوه هو نابليون
لذلك من المهم جدا
ثم كان الجنرال الذي صنع
كامل حياته العسكرية الذي مات
في معركة من مات في روسيا
اعترف جان ليونيتي مايك ماك
من الواضح أننا عرفنا أنه كان كذلك
دفن في روسيا فقط جسده
تم إعادتهم إلى فرنسا
في مقبرة بير لاشيز
نحن نخمن وهذا كل شيء
بالتأكيد قمنا بدفنه بالزي الرسمي
والزي الرسمي لجنرال إمبراطوري
الأفراد وحتى لو مضى الوقت
حتى لو ذهب القماش
سوف يبقى رودريغ المعدني
[موسيقى]
ولكن ربما 80 90٪ فرصة أن
دفن الجنرال للوحدات الإضافية
لا
[موسيقى]
غير قادر على مواجهة قماش جيد
جنرال لواء
حددنا مكان مزروع
قبضة السبر في محور
تألق معاقل في الواقع
النتائج الأولى تشير إلى أن
قبر غيسان العام لا نفعل ذلك
لا أجد اللمعان ، إنها خيبة أمل
في الواقع لكني لست كذلك
الأكثر تضررا من هذا الجزء هذا العمل
لأن وظيفتي هي
الباحثين لتقديم الفرضيات
للذهاب إلى الميدان والتحقق
ob الجسد في كندا ولكن لدي كل
قسم السماء الفرنسية في كرة القدم
الكثير من المواهب ماتت مقتولة ولكن
لولا
فكرة القيام بمشروع كبير
الجيش في الحملة الروسية هو أ
المشروع الذي بدأت به أكثر من
عامين كنت أرغب في القيام بمشروع
الذين كانت لهم علاقة بين فرنسا
وروسيا ولجنرال الرقص
إنه مميز حقًا منذ dudin
لا أحد يعرفني أيضًا
ومع ذلك لديه شارع في السادس عشر
حي في باريس
إنه على قوس النصر لكنه خسر
من كاليفورنيا قال لي شيئا وعندما كنت
نظرت إلى سيرته الذاتية التي وقعت بها
الأرض قلت لنفسي أنهم كانوا فيها
المدرسة مع نابليون عندما كان في العاشرة من عمره
سنوات حتى عرف نابليون ثم ملكه
طفولته وكانت من أفضل ما لديه
أصدقاء منذ بعد تتويج
الامبراطور
إنه أحد الأشخاص الوحيدين الذين اتصلوا به على
أخبرته ساحة المعركة أنك لست كذلك
أنت جيدة فرنسا
[موسيقى]
فريدريك لومير في طاه الخلود
بريندا والجنرال وجعله كذلك
استدعاء ساندرين ليون بما في ذلك أربعة في
وبالتالي إجهادهم ومنارة
أليس يركل دفنيا المجاهد
ميلا المدفأة لدينا حوالي عشرين
الناس الذين جاءوا من فرنسا
لمدة شهر وكان هناك
خمسة عشر حوالي عشرين شارعًا أيضًا
إنها متساوية ولديهم
عملت لدى 40 شخصًا من أجلي
كان لدي أداة جديدة في MCS بأي حال من الأحوال
معها يجذبني أيضا أشعر أنني بحالة جيدة و
الكراك الشرير وهناك فعلنا ذلك على هذا النحو
[موسيقى]
لذلك بعد أن لا يزال هناك حد أقصى فعال
بطيء
كانديس ثم ميثاقها جاستن أغسطس
سنوات عليه ثم لويس و
القادة نحاول حقا
فهم مسار المعركة
بواسطة د
في الواقع القطع الأثرية ذات الصلة بفالمونت
للقتال
الكرات التي تعمل على
توزيع هذه الأشياء نحن
وجدت على السطح
على وجه الخصوص بمساعدة أجهزة الكشف
المعادن ثم خاصة لوضعها
أبلغ عن هذا الفهم للموقع من خلال
علم الآثار مع المقبرة الجماعية التي
يحتوي على رفات الجنود الذين
مات على وجه التحديد في الاعتداء سبعة
ركض أهداف لسابرينا و iphoneos
ولدت ميكلين ولاتينوس في الكوليت
سوف تتفاعل قوى روسيا
تؤكل تماما في نابليون
الجزائر xinhua
[موسيقى]
يود أن أقول لك
البطاريات عند الخمول فقط
تفضل
هو
لذلك ابق محطمًا الشيء الآخر بعيدًا
القمار
[تصفيق]
الجنرال جاودين الذي سيأتي لم يكن كذلك
ليس متسابقًا جيدًا لعبور هذا
نهر تم تدمير الجسر و
لذلك علينا عبور هذا القليل
بناء النهر وفي الواقع قرروا ذلك
ترجل لعبور
النهر وهو برفع الحصان
الذي يؤلمه بالفعل قذيفة مدفع
قاتلة
almanac hello year logo magic
كان سمولينسك في ليتشي قناة فرنسا عليه
سوف تأجيرها ميدان ineo mini camellini
السيدة إيدان أنا أدعمك
يعطي أصوات الباس للواتسا المحلية
الطازجة العضوية les toques dzama rally lille
الوطن يدفع لوصيفه زاعمًا ذلك
ذكريات التلفزيون والراديو ليست
ثقب العنصرية يقع في ألمانيا أ
من أفضل المكالمات الهاتفية والعامة
إلى رشقات نارية هناك في dailymotion الداخلة
وهو في الواقع كنا نظن والدي
وانا القبر اختفى متى
معارك سمولينسك في عام 1941 عندما
قصف الألمان المنطقة
كنا نظن أن هذا كان عندما
اختفى القبر وهكذا هؤلاء
فرق البحث الذين لديهم
علمت أنه لا يوجد بداهة كان هناك فقط
تم نسيانه وأنه كان هناك خير
فرص العثور عليها
[موسيقى]
حتى اللعبة
gudin العام هو ذلك ست مرات
الجد الأكبر من جانب والدي
الموت في سمولينسك
من تزوج
ماري كروزر
الألمانية حتى يقرؤوا ابنهم
عام إيدا صغار 2 ثم أنا
مع ماريا نيكولاي أفيناس طروادة كالاس
أطفالنا الثلاثة ليتفين دري آن و
روبرت
لذلك نحن هنا ننتقل بين الجنرال إيدا
حتى الموت في سمولينسك وأولادي
يمكن الاعتماد لديك لي هنا
توليد
لذلك طلب جوادان موته
نابليون يعتني بأطفاله
أوفى نابليون بكلمته وسأل
أرملة الجنرال إذا استطاعت
أن يعهد إلى ابنه البكر لخدمته
مثل الصفحة
الرسالة التي كتبها نابليون
زوجة الغنيمة العامة ل
لإبلاغها بوفاة زوجها
لأن adq
لذلك أخبرها أنهم يشاركون
عقوبته
من يفكر بها ، في عائلتها
يشرح لها
كيف تجري الامور
تمر عليهم في المستقبل
اسمي فريدريك لومير أنا
عالم آثار في المعهد
البحوث الأثرية الوطنية
وقائي
أنا أعمل في علم الآثار
الصراعات الأخيرة في الأول من
نزاعين عالميين في القرن العشرين
أيضا الحروب النابليونية
هناك واحد في عام 2017 لأن malinowski الذي
يرأس مؤسسة
في موسكو مؤسسة فرنسية روسية
يروج للمبادرات الثقافية و
التاريخ اتصل بي عبر
نابليون لتشكيل
فريق من الباحثين فريق
من علماء الآثار المحترفين ل
إجراء الحفريات في سمولينسك و
منطقة سمولينسك مع
ولا سيما مشكلة
موقع قبر الجنرال
gudin لذلك هناك منذ أن عملنا
الكثير عن الجنرال دييدا
منذ أملنا مهمتنا
واحد الدببة على فضائنا
لمحاولة العثور على قبره و
نسأل أنفسنا السؤال إذا اكتشفنا
عام الكومة هو ما سيبقى
شهادة عن شخصيته و أ
جزء من زيها
حتى لو كان هناك وقت قد مضى علينا
سوف تجد الشعاب المرجانية خاصة الأجزاء
mechali معركة أولئك الذين سوف يتحملون
في الوقت المناسب وبالتالي من بيب
ارتدى هذا النوع من الزي الرسمي وبالتالي
تخصصي بالطبع
معدات الجندي العسكري وما إلى ذلك
هو أن نكون قادرين على المصادقة على ما نحن عليه
سوف تجد في الأرض ومعرفة من
يتعلق بهذا العنصر أو ذاك
اكتشف ذلك في الواقع
هناك نوعان من الأماكن المحتملة
سمولينسك
يمكننا العثور على جثة الجنرال
الغنيمة لذلك هناك بالفعل مناقشة ل
هذا المستوى لدي فكرة وأعتقد
أنه إذا بدأنا الحفر في هذا
مكان هناك لدينا فرصة أفضل بكثير
للعثور على جثة ليسيسترشاير أنا
نتحدث عن معقل شاينر الذي نملكه
ربما عشرات الشهادات و
من دراسة عبور هؤلاء
شهادتين فرضيتين صاغتهما
فرضيتان للموقع
الأول الذي يقوم على دعوته
فرضية سيغور التي هي بلاس ما
على أساس شهادة 2.2 من
مساعد الجنرال سيجور نابليون
والصبيان هناك والفرضية الثانية هي
فرضية الشباب للجنرال الشباب
من هو المسؤول عن des
جنازة موكب جنازة
دويتس الثاني موكب الجنازة المحدودة
دفن 2 من ghislain العامة و
هذه الفرضية تحدد موقع الضريح
هذه أفضل فرضية
معقول إنها فرضية
اليوم من الناحية النظرية هناك القليل
قريب
إذا كان لا بد من التعبير عنها في
النسبة المئوية أو ربما 80 90٪
فرصة أن دفن الجنرال
gudin يكون هناك كان الفرنسيون
نختار الشغف الذي قاله الروس
أردت أن تختار
قال الروس ما تريدون و
علماء الآثار الروس
روف مع زوجها يقول لي نادين
مركز الزاوية ليس فقط إلى pensum
الشيء الذي تخبرنا به الحقيقة ثم هناك
غادرنا لمدة شهر للتنقيب
مكان حيث نحن على يقين من عدم العثور عليه
دليل للقيام به كان علينا المشاركة لدينا
تم تصويره أو هناك
الصينية باستيان الذي كان يفعل
جزء من تحصينات مدينة
سمولينسك والذي هو اليوم في الواقع
حديقة
تأخر
و
أعتقد أن والديه هم فقط هؤلاء
الذين هم مرتبطون بالوحوش القذرة سواء له
سجل
تقرر بين المرارة والجميع
الاختلاف هنا فقط
طيب بركة لتغيير رأيك
الجانب السلبي ترك صرصور المستقبل تماما مثل
ذلك منه
من تحميلها
بعد التصويت لممارسة كافية
موتويرت
هناك إذا كان لديك حدود واضحة
الذي يظهر الشيء الذي يجعل اثنين أو
ثلاثة أمتار مربعة في وسط
تل
الاحتمال مرتفع جدًا بالفعل
نحن نواجه جدا
سنفهم بسرعة أننا نمحو
هيكل من هذه الهياكل
الحفريات الأثرية
شاليه روسليت متصل بالتصنيع
ألبرتا
[موسيقى]
الطريق الذي يترك الأشياء للقراءة
أيضا في المقابل على اليسار دعا ل
البشع
لذلك يمكننا القول أنه إذا كان لدينا
سوء الحظ عدم العثور على قبر
جنرال لواء
إذا كانت قد تعرضت بالفعل للنهب من قبل
قليلا مثل وادي
ملوك للمصريين إذا لم يكن لدينا
هذا الشيء الذي سنكون عليه نستطيع
التراجع عن أعمال التنقيب في loubineaud
أو هناك سيكون لدينا بالفعل شيء بالفعل
شيء مثير للاهتمام للغاية للتعامل معه ولكن
صحيح أن الهدف سيكون
العثور على قبر الجنرال سيكون
غير عادى
ولكن ربما تم ذلك بالفعل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لذلك أخذ سوني كأس ألاتشاتي إلى موقعه
البيرة تحب جميعًا القيام بعملنا
لدي الكثير من 3 وها هو
تنتهي المهمة ونحن نعد أ
دعونا نحزم أربعة أيام من
رحلة تنتظرنا
ومن ثم احتفلنا الليلة الماضية
رحيل مع فريق بروس زميل
الروسية
شربنا بعض الكحول الروسي
إنها هدية ولكن الهدايا المقدمة
مونولوج الكسندر في حد ذاته في الشهر
يفصل بعيدًا جدًا عن كونه فاشلاً و
كل الفرنسيين جدا جدا
سعيد جدا مع هذا
تجربة السفر من هذه المهمة إلى
سمولينسك بالنسبة لهم هو
التغيير الكلي لمشهد روسيا لل
أصغر وأقل شبابًا ممن لا يفعلون ذلك
لا أعرف ما يقولون
اكتشف
الى
طريقة حياة فعلها ماضي
لا أكون قد جعلني لا أقبل
تقلبات من القدر أنا فقط
أنا بالفعل باحث
من لعبة لا أكذب كنت سأفعل
أحب أن يكتشف قبره
دراما البسام هذه تتسع لـ
7.6 يحد من ثقته التنفيذية في عمليات الاستحواذ على
رودون ضد تونس
حتى قلعة الحرب فيها
نحن
هو واحد من أقدم المنازل في
عائلات في فرنسا منذ الأسرة
هو أب غير منقطع في
ابن منذ القرن الرابع عشر
لقد كانت موجودة الآن
monfils للجيل الرابع والعشرين من
الأسرة لنرى
تعيش هنا ربما تكون هناك
أحدث طاقم التلفزيون قريبا
مقابلة معنا هنا منذ أن فعلنا
اضطررت إلى اتخاذ القرار
تخسر وقلعة
حاليا تحتفظ بهذا النوع من
بناء نتساءل المزيد والمزيد عنه
كلا يعني وعمل بلدي
أنا وزوجة فعلنا ذلك من أجل
عدة سنوات
لكن في هذه الحالة جسديًا لا نصل
المزيد لمتابعة للترحيب
ستة من الناس نظموا
حفلات الاستقبال ولذا قررنا
افصلنا
آمل أن ينقذنا من عيش أ
الدراما مثل تلك التي وصفها
تشيخوف في إحدى مسرحياته
بستان الكرز باللغة الفرنسية
[موسيقى]
مصنع الكونغ فو ينهي مسيرتي
موازية م بعد أن ننتهي
أول حصن بقيت فيه
الهدوء والخميس نقوم بتغيير نقوم به
الاحتمال الثاني نحن
أتيت هنا مع الإسكندر وعندما كنت
بالنظر إلى التصميم وكل ما قلناه
حفر الريل لأن لماذا
لقد اخترت المشاعر منذ ذلك الحين
أ ولكن في ذكريات سيغور هو
يشرح عندما تدخل
الباب القديم الذي يقف على
معقل كبير على اليمين ولكن قبل كل شيء
يتحدث عن كومة تل هو أ
مكان نضع فيه طهاة رائعين
غاليك في ذلك الوقت وكل ذلك بالنسبة لي
أضع نفسي في وسط القلعة
قلت لنفسي إذا كنت نابليون حيث أنا
ضع الرجل الذي أضعه صديقي وهناك لدي
رأيت الكومة بالنسبة لي التي كانت أكثر
متوسط
قلت لنفسي إنني سأصعد إلى الطابق العلوي
مثالي لتنظيم الجنازات
هو صديقي ولدي الصورة أنا
أنا مثل هذا يظهر
المكان الذي أحفر فيه نفسي وقال لي هناك نحن
سوف متوسط
جريد
لا يعطي شيئا
مستوى سم الحركة ميكا الذين يحبونه
كبيرة جدا
لماذا
كنا جميعا
تزلج
م
دوس سانتوس
[موسيقى]
امستردام
سؤال مترو الانفاق من ليحل محل
جمال حفلة ناجحة للجميع
عام لا يصنع الأحبة هناك أبدًا
قلقنا غير مرئي
[موسيقى]
يمكن أن تؤكد على التأكيد بشكل قاطع
هذا هو العام جودارد ، نعم
لا يوجد حتى بدون الجسد العادل بالفعل
الموقف لبدء الموقف
من الجسم هنا في الوسط مع المحفوظات
بعد إذا تحدثنا فقط حصريًا عن
الجسم هناك شيئان حقا جدا
المهم والساق
قطع الساق بالفعل ارتفاع فوق
الركبة مثل مذكرات
طبيب جراح نابليون
نابليون والساق الثانية أيضًا
أنهم تضرروا يمكننا أن نرى
الآثار التي تم لمسها
علامات التأثير
و
هناك الكثير في الواقع هناك كل شيء
هذا المزيج منذ عام
العمل على تحضير المشروع بأكمله
منذ البداية
وعندما تصل
نرى تسديدات على المرمى لنجدها
لحظة تاريخية حتى في بعض الأحيان فقط
بالنسبة لي أعتقد لبلدنا
لذلك لم يكن هناك الكثير من العاطفة
في نفس الوقت على أي حال لم أكن لأفعل ذلك
تم العثور على المعتقلين
[موسيقى]
نعم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
منع أي رسم ما هذا
أعطها ما عليك سوى لقوانين كوناس
لا تكبر ، هذا يقلقني
فاز بهيكل
توماس لديه
الفريقين الديناميكيين و
سجل عن طريق التزلج في الهيبة
ويليام لاروشيل
الذي - التي
- الحجم الأصلي وحلقات
من سيرشد آكيتاين
[موسيقى]
كن لطيفا هنا اليوم هو
لحظة سوف نقول التاريخية جسر
المباركة على الصداقة الفرنسية الروسية التي
معجب به
[موسيقى]
فرصة لإثبات على الرغم من
أرشفة لهم
المعلومات التي كانت لدينا هي
المشروع الذي كان قيد الإعداد هو أ
التعاون من الدعم الروسي و
الفرنسية
[موسيقى]
شكرا
تشارك اثنين
المفهوم
[موسيقى]
منذ هذا النوع
ز
الجنرالات
أحفاد الفرنسيين و
[موسيقى]
وبالنسبة لي موظفينا وسوف نقول
ما اريده عامة وفرنسا
وأعتقد أن ذلك سيحدث منذ ذلك الحين
هؤلاء الناس من قبل الفرنسيين يستحقون
اقلب تزلجه
[موسيقى]